hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
chapter four of book five of the
brothers karamazov
culminates in an argument or
you might say a stance being taken by
one of the brothers ivan in his
conversation it's a fairly one-sided
conversation with his brother
alyosha and ivan is
setting out a problematic that we can
identify
as what's called the problem of evil
in philosophy of religion namely if
there is this great
god then why do we have so much
suffering and evil and misery
in the world how can we reconcile the
traditional attributes of god and all of
this
terrible stuff that we see and ivan is
very
an interesting case here because he
doesn't just talk about what happens to
other people or what he sees other
people doing
he even talks about his own bad deeds
and so he's conscious of this as not
just a problem but a problem that
involves him as well
and he's going to set out a resolution
though not
solution to this this issue
which eliot identifies as rebellion
although ivan is going to say it's not
actually
just rebellion and we want to look at
the way in which he
sets it up but first we want to look at
what his
his main issue or complaint
is he says we have this problem
of human suffering and he laid out the
suffering of children
with quite a few cases including a child
who
became an adult had a really screwed up
life gets executed
as a result of crimes that he commits
human responsibility
and freedom do these things actually
make sense in any way and you know if
you think about
suffering itself when a person is
suffering
there's a kind of revolt or rebellion
against it sometimes there's
acquiescence in it as well
or even a kind of collaboration with it
but that's that's not an
immediate response and there is a
tendency to say
what what is this about why does this
have to happen
why are things the way they are and so
ivan says
i took children to make it more obvious
about all the other human tears that
have soaked the whole world through from
crust to core i don't say a word i've
purposely narrowed down my
theme and he says i don't understand why
things are arranged
as they are and then he lays out
what we could call three possibilities
so
one of these and you could you could
look at this in terms
of you know his reference to the
biblical
garden of eden and adam and eve and
eating of the apple or rather fruit
because
it's not actually called an apple in the
genesis account
and the
learning or realization
of a greater dimension to life knowledge
of good and evil before that
adam and eve were innocent after eating
the apple
not only are they screwed up because
they disobeyed god
that we can actually put that to the
side they're also screwed up because
they're now
aware of things in a very different way
and we don't necessarily have to use
this biblical account
to talk about how human beings
by virtue of being the kind of creatures
that we are
are screwed up in that way ivan puts it
in terms of
humans wanted freedom and they wanted
knowledge of good and evil so you could
say
that's what comes with it too bad you're
kind of stuck
people are going to suffer including the
ones who are tormentors but
even more the ones who are tormented he
says
they were given paradise they wanted
freedom they stole fire from heaven
knowing they would become unhappy
why pity them this is in fact a stance
that many people take
ivan does not take that stance himself
he's just saying that's a possibility
there's another stance that's also
possible which he is tempted by
but doesn't find satisfactory
and you could associate this with a kind
of you know
view of life as just
cause an effect that can be understood
through the sciences
or through positivism in philosophy
you know sort of a reductive view on
human beings in reality and he says
with my pathetic earthly euclidean
mind he's using euclid and geometry
there is sort of an example he could
have said newtonian he could have said
whatever
so he says i know that there is
suffering
and that none are to blame that all
things follow simply and directly from
another from another that
everything flows and finds its level so
this is a sort of
viewpoint on things that says well
people do
bad things to each other they're not
truly bad they're just
things and they're you know motivated or
necessitated by psychological laws and
dynamics and the traumas that they've
gone through
nobody's really to blame people just do
what they do
according to you know all how all these
natural laws and causes and effect fit
together
now then he says that's all just
euclidean gibberish
of course i know that and of course i
cannot consent to live by it
this is very interesting he's saying you
know in a certain sense this is true
but i can't actually follow it and
live with it you may have all these laws
of nature that have been discovered
that can't be the whole story so
here he talks about something else that
is discussed under the aspect of
retribution
we hear this word retribution we think
of revenge
we think of imposing some suffering on
somebody
who's made somebody else suffer right
and
what sometimes gets left out of this is
that retribution can in fact
be a rectification it can involve
justice it can uh you know through
punishment sometimes
make the bad person realize their
badness and want to change want to
become
better so he talks here
about retribution and he says i need
retribution otherwise i will destroy
myself
and retribution not somewhere
and sometime in infinity but here and
now
on earth i want to see that the
the bad things that have been done are
somehow
taken into account and the evil-doers
are punished
and something is restored to those who
had something taken away from them
i want to see this happening here on
earth i have this desire
he knows that that's not going to happen
he's given plenty of examples of cases
where it simply
can't happen the child is dead you're
not going to get a child back you can't
have the child
uneaten by the dogs or you can't have
the
the young man uh un unhung
or un-guillotined or anything like that
you can't have his parents um feed him
and clothe him when they they ought to
have
so these are three different possible
responses another possible response that
a lot of people make
and not just religious people sometimes
secular people as well
they'll say well this is all part of
some you know great
plan and this goes beyond the you know
euclidean point of view
which says listen there's suffering it's
just the way it is you know
cause and effect laws and all that this
says this is actually arranged in some
way that it brings about a better result
it could be you know a sort of secular
uh progressivism that says well all of
this is actually for the good of
humanity later on
all of this suffering will be redeemed
and recovered somehow
could be religious he he says that um
i want to see for myself so let them
resurrect me
is it possible that i've suffered so
that i together with my evil deeds and
suffering should be manure for someone's
future harmony i want to see with my own
eyes behind
lie down with the lion and the murdered
man rise up and embrace
his murder i want to be there when
everyone suddenly finds out
what it was all for how
all of this figured into some
future higher harmony
a concordance is another word of talking
about this
and here we actually ought to take a
pause
it's interesting that he frames things
in this way
i think a lot of people are used to
consoling themself with harm that's done
and killing and all sorts of trauma
and abuse by saying well you know
the person who suffered that will get to
heaven or some other thing
and it's going to be a okay for them and
so that is a christian motif right but
traditional christianity never stressed
the individual having their own little
afterlife all by themselves the
afterlife
is supposed to be for for paradise or
for
heaven it's supposed to be a harmony a
concord it's not just
you getting to enjoy whatever you want
because life sucked for you back then on
earth
no it's something different you fit in
with all these other people and some for
example talks about
is he speculating about what the joy in
heaven is going to be like
everybody having their own will but it
also
harmonizing with everybody else's will
in the divine will
so we don't lose any of our humanity
but we are part of a community in fact
you might
say the community that all other
communities are
merely a dim reflection of so
that's one of the answers that's often
given and he says
this doesn't satisfy me i i can't go
along with this
on the one hand all religions on earth
he says are based on desire for this so
there's something
in the human being that really wants to
have something that we don't have
this entire agreement this entire
valuing of everybody by everybody else
but children's suffering poses a set of
real
significant problems he says if children
must suffer in order to buy eternal
harmony
with their suffering tell me what
children have got to do with it
it's incomprehensible why they should
have to suffer
and why they should buy harmony with
their suffering
why do they get thrown on the pile to
manure someone's future harmony
with themselves so on the one hand you
can say
how does the suffering of children
actually make anything
better and generate this this future
condition
in which we're all going to be like on
the same page and then how is it good
for these children themselves
they they didn't deserve to suffer how
is this going to
match up with this this harmony and he
says
if it's really true that they're in
solidarity with their fathers and all
the fathers evil doing
that truth is certainly not of this
world and is incomprehensible to me i
can't buy that sort of explanation
well we all sinned in adam so what
children aren't actually
sinful at the point that we're talking
about according to
ivan and according to traditional
understandings of the age of reason
and culpability or guilt
he goes on and he says some joker will
say perhaps in any case the child will
grow up and have time enough to sin
but that's not the case of the children
i'm talking about the boy who was torn
apart by dogs
he was too young to have had that happen
he did an innocent little act that hurt
a dog's paw and he had himself torn
apart
by a wicked general who had him hunted
by his dogs
as a result there's no way to make that
map
into or map onto this harmony
he goes on and he says um
it may be that if i live until that
moment or rise again in order to see it
i myself will perhaps cry out with all
the rest looking at
the mother embracing her child's
tormentor just are thou
o lord but i don't want to cry out with
them
why not the mother could
forgive the general for killing her
child in a horrible way
for for you know trivial reasons
for engaging in an evil act but the
mother can't forgive
on behalf of the child that would be
wrong
according to ivan he says
even if you do avenge them can they be
redeemed by being avenged
what do i care if they're revenge or do
i care if the tormentors are in hell
what can hell set right here if these
ones have already been tormented
sending the evil-doers down to the hell
doesn't make things better
for all the children who have been
brutalized who have been
raped who've been killed who've been
tormented
in their lifetimes and you know if there
is hell
how does that fit into this this future
harmony as well
so ivan stance that he takes here which
is being labeled as rebellion
by alyosha an existential stance where
he's taking responsibility for this own
stance
he knows that it's in some respect
irrational but this is
in fact what he says he has to do he
says
i'm going to remain with this
suffering and indignation
he says even if i'm wrong
i don't want harmony for love of mankind
i don't want it
i want to remain with unrequited
suffering
even if i'm wrong so he knows that
there's the possibility of getting
things wrong
and then he's got this interesting
metaphor of returning the ticket what
does that mean
the ticket is this acceptance of
all of these things that are happening
in the name of some
you know to come future higher harmony
that we could perhaps have faith in
and he says i can't buy that and the
right thing for me to do is not just to
wait until the end and then say ah
you know i don't buy it now it's to say
i don't buy this in advance god you keep
your deal
i'm not going to go along with it i
can't change the nature of the deal
but i do at least control whether i
assent
or refuse and i refuse
so alyosha after uh
ivan says i'm i'm just most respectfully
return
to god the ticket i i do accept god
but i'm not going to buy into this deal
and alyosha says
that's rebellion and ivan says i don't
like hearing such a word from you
one cannot live by rebellion
and i want to live so there's something
more that ivan is looking for other than
just
a refusal and again this is reflecting a
deeply existential stance
towards this problem of suffering
misery evil here that we experience
as applied in particular to those who
you would think are the most innocent
children this
is ivan's rebellion better understood as
returning the ticket in advance
you